yeah welcome to this video playing I am
Stefan off from Bulgaria I suppose yeah
okay on the fantasy variation I had a
look at this line and I thought this
would be quite fine for black k is
playing immediately night f2 bag
interesting isn't this just immediately
good for black with this um bad pour hmm
yeah this is not the kind of line that
will cause black players sleepless
nights hmm night 95 night before lots of
good good ideas can also just go here t5
I just moved the Queen somewhere and it
season the pin so night to d5 just the
simple okayed ya can try to be a bit
quicker this time the position is so
comfortable anyway so just play quickly
rookie 70 movie has got night to night c
5 i'm starting to a long time again for
no particular reason should I shut up
play yeah that's a wide range of
possibilities rookie supplies got nights
if I if I don't want dad maybe regroup
this it's a young okay sometimes you
just need to pass ourselves just do
nothing and let him weekend well hurry I
go I go down those kind of um week
squares I like to like to do them may be
here a three
so take a three now maybe this isn't
that the latest greatest best but it's
upon at least a pawn for the moment
and before us every week if he exchanges
on a six now and I don't really see what
else oh this is why I should have seen
that this is move at least now maybe it
is not so terrible okay one I can play
Quimby five when I cannot wait wait wait
wait wait I had Italy bandar the slide
this is bad
okay yeah I'm trying to try to hold this
so this is immensely stupid giving away
the piece I mean this is probably the
most comfortable ever isolated queen
palm position and i managed to just
blunder this away okay see for it's got
95 this is the tip d plant that's right
and ok possible but it's just I have the
dip on 95 takes 97 King night see and
I've got d to immediate immediately so
what is happening now I just take it
yeah d 2 isn't this winning wait wait
wait wait not just a second t2 it's not
winning of course but it's a it's enough
let's not to lose
wait painted happy the background made
at the end arc how on earth is this
possible yeah and this is proof that
that is luck in chess he never ever
planned this can forget about that when
he allowed see form he just blundered
this okay but still continue there's
always some chances and in this kind of
positions to to defend
check
check
and I ya know well okay i'm also very
much Donald time check I'm warning
yet yeah it's a bit pointless even if he
M blunders this into Brooke bishop
against look how am I going to to hold
that in 12 seconds ok let's resign yeah
okay I need to be a bit a bit modest
here after plundering the piece but this
is just funny I mean 93's just didn't
see this move obviously and it was just
walking by this funny coincidence that d
to this is exactly the city's exactly
this is working due to this fact that
now this is a bad just you also place
Knight c3 if I've half the porn on age
six and then like wins straightaway off
as a rook endgame with an good mixture
porn ah yeah but blundering the piece
was really terrible I mean the way he
played this I'm sorry I mean cannot go
into an isolated pawn position where you
give up all light squares and have a
dead bishop on f2 unless the opponent
blunders pieces you are you're bound to
lose this is clear yeah but i blundered
apiece yeah thanks for watching